alors on continue la discussion avec
l'avocat qui représente 13 du canada
christian leblanc manger au quotidien je
vous appelle alors je vous demanderai
pas de refaire votre plaidoirie mais en
deux mots le essentiellement qu'est-ce
que vous avez soumis au juge on a soumis
deux choses d'abord on a indiqué qu'un
tel procès un tel processus ne devrait
pas avoir lieu c'est à dire que l'on
devrait avoir accès au dossier en tant
que le plus possible au dossier et
deuxièmement on assume un processus
c'est-à-dire remettez-nous les documents
qui sans révéler l'identité de
l'indicateur de police pourrait nous
permettre de plaider intelligemment et
d' éclairer la cour sur est-ce que tout
le dossier doit rester à huis clos ou
non lorsque ça c'est la question un peu
étrange ce à dire que quand on est un
avocat et qu'on sait pas ce que notre
vis-à-vis plaide c'est un put c'est un
peu déconcertant ne pas savoir à quoi on
s'oppose mais tout à fait en fait tout
notre système de justice est construit
de cette façon là à la cour est éclairé
par la position des deux parties sinon
qu'elle a le privilège et c'est pas
juste l'avocat qui plaide mais aussi la
cour qui reçoit elle a le privilège
d'avoir les deux côtés de la médaille si
l'on veut ici c'est pas vraiment
possible puisqu'on ne sait pas ce que
contient le dossier certes il ya des
grands principes c'est ce qu'on a
souligné aujourd'hui nous on aimerait
être un peu plus pratique et pouvoir
démontrer à la cour que certaines
informations du moins objectivement sans
connaître ce qui contient dans le
dossier pourrait être révélée sans
mettre en péril l'identité de
l'indicateur de policiers évidemment
qu'il est le plus grand danger de tenir
un procès dans un secret aussi absolue
que celui qu'on connaît dans l'histoire
qu'on connaît pas
en fait il faut revenir à la genèse de
son pourquoi les médias se bat pour la
publicité des débats judiciaires
pourquoi les cours ont toujours dit que
c'est un principe très important la cour
d'appel d'ailleurs dans cette dans cette
affaire si le dit également c'est parce
que pour avoir une pleine confiance dans
son système de justice le citoyen doit
voir ce qui se passe devant la cour si
c'est fait de façon cachée si on ne sait
pas ce qui se passe c'est souvent le
début de la perte de confiance on
comprend pas pourquoi il ya eu un
acquittement on comprend pas pourquoi
quelqu'un est trouvé coupable
même chose dans des procédures civiles
alors que si on voit et on a un très bon
système de justice y on voit comment le
système de justice se déroule la
confiance est maintenue donc il faut
avoir de plus la plus grande
transparence possible
d'ailleurs j'ai entendu cet argument là
de votre part parce que j'écoutais au
téléphone vous avez dit ce pourquoi la
réaction était si forte de la part du
juge dans shift la cour supérieure le
juge en chef de la cour suprême c'est
quand même pas rien c'est que les
tribunaux sont redevables si on sait pas
c'est qui le tribunal le juge lipova de
vente de rien c'est ça qui est
inquiétant mais oui je les plaies des
aujourd'hui devant la cour d'appel par
exemple le nom du juge et c'est pas pour
viser le juge mais de façon générale
quand la population quand les citoyens
regarder se disent un jugement a été
rendu sur la culpabilité on nous parle
d'un crime grave on connaît pas la
nature du crime mais même le juge qui a
participé à ce dossier ne peut pas on ne
peut pas être connu c'est la même chose
avec les procureurs les procureurs de la
poursuite des personnes désignées donc
de cet indicateur sont toujours sous le
sceau d'un huis clos on ne les connaît
pas c'est une redevance que je vous
dirais assez de base que de connaître
les gens impliqués et en même temps on a
dit à la cour d'appel il est difficile
de comprendre malgré le fait qu'on ne
sait pas ce que contient le dossier
comment avoir cette information là
pourrait nous amener à découvrir
l'identité d'un indicateur de police
effectivement c'est assez
incompréhensible
évidemment c'est un principe fondamental
qu'on connaît tous celui de la publicité
des débats la transparence du système
judiciaire pourquoi est-ce qu'ils si
important et si sacré c'est pas juste
parce qu'on veut tout savoir nous les
journalistes il ya un fondement à sal
oui l'histoire nous enseigne que lorsque
les gens ne savent pas ce qui se passe
dans un lieu donné on imagine le pays et
le danger avec le système de justice
c'est pas juste qu'on imagine la
mauvaise fin du film c'est qu'on
commence à perdre confiance la confiance
s'érode et si on ne perd confiance dans
le système de justice on commence à se
faire justice soi même et ça c'est
l'anarchie et c'est vraiment pas une
bonne chose et c'est pas des grands
principes c'est comme ça que ça doit
être tenu justement pour maintenir cette
confiance si jamais on va spéculer
puisque c'est ce qu'on peut faire dans
cette affaire là si jamais c'était
avalisé par les tribunaux supérieurs
encore plus supérieur qu'à la cour
d'appel il ya un danger que ça se répète
d'ailleurs qu'est ce qui nous dit qu'il
y en a pas d'autre secret écoutez ce que
la cour d'appel nous a révélé dans son
jugement nous inquiète tous alors le
fait et on verra si c'est vraiment comme
ça que ça s'est passé mais on 18
jugement de la cour d'appel qu'il n'y a
pas eu de numéro de dossier de
constituer ou que s'il ya un numéro de
dossier il a été complètement occulté
donc l'existence même du procès a été
complètement
gardé secret et une différence entre
savoir qu'il y ait un procès qui se
déroule par ailleurs à huis clos et ne
même pas savoir qu'il y ait un procès et
c'est ça qui va loin ici et qui est
inquiétant et qui est pas susceptible de
rassurer le public dans cette confiance
qu'il doit avoir dans son système de
justice donc on va se mettre à imaginer
quand on a peut-être tout plein de ces
procès secret mon succès inquiétant et
allemand l espérons que non alors en
partant de cette décision de la cour
d'appel merci beaucoup christian leblanc
merci isabelle
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]